when it comes to maths australia has
been wooed by wu
that's eddie wu to you
because his favorite math teacher has
written another book and he joins us now
eddie great to have you on the show
again this is the second book in your
magical math
series what's so magical about maths you
think well mathematics can allow us to
do
crazy and impossible things and the book
is all about exploring you know
how for example we can take 16 really
important digits to you
i assume your credit card number and
have that copied all the way around the
world every time you order something
online and yet
we can keep it safe that's all thanks to
do with mathematics and cryptography
that seems pretty magical to me
and it can do a lot of other things as
well besides eddie the book has a bunch
of activities for kids but it also
mentions
snowflakes lightning and lungs what do
these have to do with maths
well geometry the mathematics of shapes
is one of my favorite bits of
mathematics because a lot of people
sort of experience it and enjoy it like
we can all stand in front of a beautiful
piece of art
or admire a beautiful wall and not
necessarily know
why we're admiring or why there's like
an aesthetic sense to it but actually
there are mathematical rules underneath
all of those things and the book is
about helping kids especially
really practically explore that eddie
kids across the country had to adapt to
online learning this year but your
youtube channel means you're an old hand
at this did other teachers ask you for
tips
well an old hand in some ways yes in
some ways no i mean with the equipment
and you know being able to speak at a
camera that hasn't been so hard but it
has been a totally different experience
not being in the classroom with the
students around me them sort of nodding
along and saying yeah that makes sense
or like shaking their heads in confusion
and that feedback loop you know that
sort of exhaustion we're all feeling
doing everything over skype and zoom
um this is something which for me has
been new and i can definitely relate to
all of the parents out there
who are struggling with their own kids
trying to you know wrestle with online
learning um it is really tough so
anyone who is feeling like they're not
doing a great job out there
be kind to yourself we're all on the
learning curve together it's funny you
bring that up i do want to know how did
the great eddie wu go with homeschooling
his own children
well i think it's very important to
recognize that i have a very different
relationship to my students in the
classroom as i do to my
uh children at home so you know i
struggled along with every other parent
out there
i think it's something we all want to
use to remind ourselves how much to
appreciate our kids teachers
eddie we have a question from a home
viewer uh tonight um
mathematically speaking how many wines
is too many while you're homeschooling
and that's from carrie
bitmore
tell carrie i feel for her as well i
think so long as the sun is beginning to
set
then i think it's an okay time to um
consume a little bit to ease your nerves
but
her answer is that the world is round
and so it's always settings like
somewhere eddie um i must say with my
mathematical career i
i enjoyed maths for a while and then i
must say i fell out of love with it
around grade five
six into year seven and then after that
i just i just never recovered
what would you say to parents whose kids
have maybe you know fallen out of love
or out of skill with maths
uh that's a very common experience pete
you know sort of around that year six
into seven
spot is where i think mathematics
teachers would have been introducing
all the letters into the mix and a lot
of people like algebra that's where i
just checked out
um so my advice you know based on that
is that if you've got a if you're a
parent of a child who is really
struggling with that point maybe they're
like 15
16 years old maybe they're staring down
the hsc or the vce
and my best advice is actually to go
back find that spot where it did connect
even if that was a while ago and with
the right support you can actually put
the pieces back together
and find a way back into this subject
it's part of why i created these books
well eddie wu's magical maths too uh
rhymes
which is good um and there's the book
that's what it looks like
it's available now eddie thanks very
much for joining us and i'll be taking
that for a while later
sorry next time thanks eddie
see you guys pete you've got some
homework to do yeah i gotta go back to
the long division that's the i think
that was the point
yeah the vision girl was too long for me
what about fractions
i make it longer fractions where yeah
they're an issue
i know i know a quarter half and three
quarters because that's footy i know six
times tables
that's footy afl and cricket yeah one
two three oh you know you know all the
numbers i keep going i keep going yeah